[Musique]
Guillaume Deon dans le prénom ah je sais
plus quoi dire de m'entendre clicher B
j'aimerais les garçons parce que je
porte des chemises oranges mais vous
réalisez ce que vous dites j'i visc je
suis surpris vous n' ayez pas parlé
Sam dans Camille
redouble
par je
pas tu aimes la sang oucoup j'aime la
couleur de tes
[Musique]
yeuxiletteation je suis
[Applaudissements]
désolé éoute-moi bien fils tu changes
rien 6 Mo tu es un chanteur des mod
terminé
fini T pour
t
jeouche
person éti bon d'accord très
bien et toi ça va de ce côté de quel
côté du côté
[Musique]
deamour Michel villm
redouble
jeouche
c'est ma chambre
oui bonne
nuit bonne
[Musique]
nuit et le César du meilleur second rôle
masculin est attribué
à Guillaume de tonkedc dans le prénom un
tramboniste solitaire et malmené par ses
amis au cours d'une soirée où l'un d'eux
SIME le trouble en révélant le prénom
qu'il veut donner à son enfant àêtre il
reprenait le rôle qu'il avait créé sur
scène à Édouard 7 dans la pièce de
Mathieu de la Corte et alexand de la
[Musique]
Patelière non mais quelle histoire ce
prénom c'est vraiment du délire quelle
chance quel truc
extraordinaire je bénis le jour je suis
aller lire cette pièce chez Bernard Mura
j'embrasse toute l'équipe du Théâtre ed
7 merci Bernard de m'avoir le premier
confié ce merveilleux personnage de la
prune je vois qu'il y en a qui ont vu le
film ce soir ça me fait plaisir pour les
autres il est S en VOD il est disponible
en DVD prenez-le au pire vous passerez
une bonne
soirée Dimitri Rassam Jérôme sou je suis
à fond dans la promo on se voit tout à
l'heure je vous ai dit que je vous
trouve très beau bon on s'appelle les
chers auteurs Alexandre Mathieu les gars
un acteur peut avoir du génie dans sa
salle de main mais sans un bon texte il
n'est absolument rien je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir du génie mais je suis sûr que
vous êtes des auteurs génnieiaux et en
plus des gens bien mes chers partenaires
Patrick ch Charles vive la testostérone
mesdemoiselle Judith Valérie équipe de
choc et de charme je vous aime j'ai vécu
un grand moment sur ce film quand une
comédienne extraordinaire mademoiselle
Françoise Fabian a écarté les bras et
m'a dit viens j'ai envie de
toi qu'est-ce que je voulais vous dire
d'autre oui on m'a dit j'embrasse toute
l'équipe du film bien sûr on m'a dit
surtout ne remercie pas ta famille tes
amis et tout tout le monde s'en fout et
ces super ringard donc permettez-moi
d'assumer ma ringardise ce soir je salue
ma famille et j'embrasse mes amis je les
ser contre mon cœur je décerne ce César
je le dédie à ma femme et à nos trois
enfants enfin je finirai en citant Louis
Jouvet il ne faut jamais ignorer la loi
essentielle de la chance qui veut qu'on
lui fasse confiance qu'on lui sourit et
qu'on l'espère ce César c'est vraiment
la cerise sur le gâteau de la prune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci